so we used to as kids we used to wander
through here and wander through the
buildings and when we were i would say
maybe 12 years old or so a bunch of us
were invited we had a Scoutmaster who
graduated from MIT and had an
affiliation and he got us one night a
week into the MIT swimming pool which to
me was unbelievable right so you know I
just saw this swimming pool back then in
the late 50s and I couldn't believe that
you know kids like us would have the
opportunity to go to a building like
that and then there were MIT students
that used to volunteer come to the Boy
Scout meetings and help teach us things
about camping and physical fitness and
you know it was a sort of a connection
so that's the early connection i had MIT
used to i guess sponsor a boy scout
troop okay i was a boy scout ok it was
troop 77 and it was in building 20 maybe
on vassar street all right we used to
meet there all right true 77 and that
was my first experience with Boy Scouts
okay and it was a great experience our
Scoutmaster was mr. Lambert okay and but
MIT donated the facility so we used to
get to go in have a scout meetings and
everything the boy scout I othas on my
honor I will do my best to do my duty to
God and country I will bathe the Scout
Law I will help other people at all
times I will keep myself physically
strong mentally awake and morally
straight that's a wonderful thing I've
never I've never forgotten it I learned
it as a kid I learned it at troop 77 MIT
building 20